bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct de ouagadougou
comment expliquez vous le fait que
l'afrique soit relativement épargné on
avait annoncé une catastrophe elle
n'aura pas lieu selon vous je pense que
la catastrophe ne l'a pas lieu et les
données statistiques justement même ciel
sont pas très fiables attendues férus de
la capacité de testing de nos pays
montre que la catastrophe
normalement nous l'a pas lieu et les
explications sont assez nombreuses déjà
le fait que les pays africains ont pu
apprendre quand même des erreurs des
autres pays qui les ont précédés peut
expliquer le fait que nous ayons moins
de deux cas et aussi il faut voir que la
population africaine est asséchée
et quand on sait que provident 19 est
beaucoup plus grave chez les populations
les plus âgées
on peut naturellement qu'on part que les
pays africains soir plus pour le tg vous
avez plus de 60% de la population qui a
moins de 25 ans et donc du coup ça se
comprend quand relégables en france ou
en italie pour les plus touchées avaient
en moyenne 75
ça peut vraiment s'explique ainsi il ya
aussi la faire une densité des pays
africains des dpe des habitants au
niveau des pays africains vous avez en
afrique la densité surtout de 43
habitants par kilomètre carré à la queue
dans les pays où blais on a environ plus
de 100 à 150
habitants par kilomètre carré c'est les
explications qui peut tenir la
circulation aussi de la population ça
paraît dans un pays africain déjà
supprimé moins que dans les autres pays
et donc ça peut aussi être un des
facteurs qui expliquent cette ces
chiffres que nous a parlé aussi beaucoup
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine que les
africains prennent puisque c'est aussi
un traitement contre le paludisme
vous pensez que ça a joué également ou
pas du tout je ne passe pas je pense que
peut-être deux les études futures
demeurant plus d'informations par
rapport à l'utilisation de la
technologie mais à mon avis reste mais
gelés par rapport à cette dimension que
la culture qu'une histoire
le facteur explicatif et du fermi tôt
dans l'année parce que je pense aussi si
les choses ont empiré l'afrique
évidemment ne pourrait pas faire face
est ce qu'elle a été est-ce que l'aide
promise notamment et l'aide demandée par
à part l'om s arrive pour faire face au
cas ou pas du tout
alors je ne sais pas vraiment mais je
sais que les pays africains se
débrouille assez bien et que quand on
regarde les l'adoption de comportements
des mesures barrières les gens tendent à
les adopter on espère que justement les
gens peuvent attendre de mieux en mieux
conscience de l'enjeu de la maladie et
qu'il devra qu'il va adopter les
comportements qui va permettre d'éviter
que thomas juste marie chaos
quel est le comportement de la
population est ce qu'il y a des craintes
s comme comme en france d'ailleurs et
comment est ce que vous voyez la
situation dans la vieille europe et
d'afrique
alors oui on fait habituellement c'est
qu'on voit comme une image c'est que le
confinement en régate que les gens
respectent énormément elle au niveau des
pays européens et que c'est ce qui est
un peu différent chez nous
cependant quand on voit ces derniers
temps avec les règles qui ont été émises
au muc qui n'a déjà promise à manifester
ont demandé à ce qu on allège juste ma
règle pour qu'il pût semaine et hakima
d'activité du tout les jours je me dis
que si on arrive à créer respecter quand
même les mesures du bac les musulmanes
hier les populations pour artix
progressivement vers la
à mener leurs activités quotidiennes
parce que justement dans nos pays le
confinement total est très très
difficile à appliquer parce que les
populations qui vivent en général au
jour le jour
arena les activités ne pouvons pas
soutenir longtemps de rester chez eux
ces actifs est ce que les frontières
sont fermées entre les pays est ce que
l'afrique contrôle également évidemment
les vols en provenance de l'étranger
bon pour ce qui concerne le burkina faso
à nous fait les frontières sont fermées
en dehors des frets et je pense que ça
continue effectivement ralentir la
propagation
oui les gens sont assez faire et comment
est-ce que les déplacements de
population notamment l'immigration on en
a parlé beaucoup en europe à ce que ces
personnes finalement maintenant ne
partent plus depuis que l'europe et est
contaminé par coronavirus est-ce que ça
râle entier en tout cas cette migration
vous pensez c'est pas mon impression
mais je pense que le fait même que les
frontières soient fermés les gens sont
obligés de rester chez eux et doit en
effet de faire que 8,19 est assez
catastrophique d'amira les gens ça vise
le faire reste effectivement chez à
l'internât que la tempête passe on a
même vu des nos frères africains quitter
l'italie
le munichois qui n'obéit mental de voir
ce qui va se passer plus tard près donc
c'est le mouvement inverse qui s'est
produit près qu'elles paient aujourd'hui
en afrique est le plus touché qu'elles
paient le moins touché
alors j'ai pas les chiffres exacts mais
je sais que le nigeria l'afrique du sud
sont assez touchés et mais bon c'est ce
que j'ai actuelle marque en chine en
tête
les mythes à la merci beaucoup mais
niane d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct de ouagadougou donc au burkina
faso merci de votre intervention sur rt
france c'est là